Let me write down for any possible outcome of the binomial, the corresponding probability.
So just for our little Python program implementing the familiar expression
of binomial distribution and with this program, I'll get the following.
Practically speaking, all the first ones have zero probability.
This is about something times 10 to the minus 5 and then over here, very small probability has come up,
and they go all the way to 0.34 for 14, somewhere between 13 and 14 is the most likely outcome,
but even those numbers aren't huge because there are so many of those up to 15.
So you've build these tables before, I spared to the work this time around
and the very basic logic here is to not draw a line such that the total probability
contained on top of the line and it's this, doesn't exceed 5%.
So here's a question for you, where would you draw the line?
If you draw it here, for example, then give me the number just on top of the line, 3.
If you're going to draw over here, it will be 13. Neither of those are correct.
Draw the line where the probability contained above the line doesn't exceed 5%.